reed hastings seems as tough as
his dvds practically indestructible
he has transformed the world of movies
tv and cable
twice we rent dvds it's a flat price
it's really easy
he's one of the people that killed the
video store
oh we would have liked nothing better
than two perry netflix
he defied his critics and bet his
company on movies by mail
when dvds were a novelty most investors
were just convinced netflix was just
another.com
it was a you know a nichey little idea
people didn't want a subscription and it
would never take off
it took off and flew high for 12 years
its value climbing
to 12 billion dollars before a
spectacular stumble stalled its growth
netflix subscribers are fleeing on mass
more than 800
000 customers canceled their service
last quarter i've heard some people say
that it feels like aliens have taken
over his body
hastings is determined to restore his
company's reputation
and his own he comes across as sort of a
typical silicon valley
executive very low-key but you know he's
one of those guys who
has to win
[Music]
10 12 years ago when we started netflix
you know the internet was still aol dial
up
but realize wow networks are just going
to grow and you know what's going to
happen
all video is going to become click and
watch internet video
everything reed hastings has made a
career out of anticipating the future
first in a software tool then with the
simple dvd
and a 32 cent stamp you won't find
anybody who has more drive than reed
hastings
he's always thinking about the
strategic shifts that need to be made he
is
an incredibly focused innovative
individual that is like smart
like light years smart he's one of those
guys who doesn't like to talk about
himself a lot
but who really feels like his actions
show
you know how good a company he can run
true to form he declined to talk about
himself for this program as well
hastings was born in boston
massachusetts in 1960
and grew up in the suburb of belmont
former governor gray davis is a friend
of hastings
he came from a middle class background
his father was a lawyer did not come
from great wealth
education is the reason he's successful
educational success included a
bachelor's degree from bowdoin college
in maine
he spent one summer in a training
program for the us marines
but realized the military wasn't for him
instead he joined the peace corps where
he taught for two years
then hitchhiked across africa with 10
bucks in his pocket
teaching was inspiring as he told
charlie rose in this 2005 conversation
well i was a high school math teacher
originally out of college
in the peace corps uh in swaziland and i
love teaching i love i taught high
school math and it was just
a fantastic experience returning to the
us
he got a masters in computer science at
stanford and landed a job at a
technology company called
adaptive corporation mark box is a
startup investor
who was introduced to hastings at the
dawn of a new era in computer
programming he said you know up until
this time
every program that's been created has
been created in the head essentially of
one person but now we're kind of getting
to the point where
it takes two three five ten guys to
write a program
and so as that starts to happen you have
problems coordinating between the people
and that creates lots of errors
errors hastings thought he could fix he
wrote a program
and started a company with mark box
called pure software
like all perfectionists hastings wanted
to hire the best
and quietly did whatever it took to get
them aki fujimora
was then an experienced software manager
at cadence design systems i didn't want
to leave
the company that i was with but then he
came over to my apartment with a six
pack of beer
and we started talking and that's his
typical style
audrey mclean was one of hastings first
investors and a board member
once we got going there was no stopping
it the company
doubled year over year for four years in
a row
so it was an absolute rocket ship
by 1995 pure software had reached the
holy grail of 90 startups
going public on opening day the stock
shot up 75 it was a very
exciting ipo in fact we were the
most successful ipo of the year in 1995
for one week the following week netscape
went public and they eclipsed it
the success landed hastings on the front
page of usa today
in front of his flashy new porsche
carrera a photo he would come to regret
cliff edwards is a technology writer for
bloomberg businessweek
i think he felt like it sort of
portrayed him as a sort of rich whiz kid
living the dream when in fact he really
wanted to show that
here's a company that he is uh nursing
uh to health and and is is pouring his
life into
two years later he sold the company for
750 million dollars
and turned his talents in a very
different direction
michael kirst is a professor emeritus of
education at stanford university
i got a call from somebody i'd never
heard of named reid hastings saying
he wanted to come to stanford and study
state education policy and politics and
i wasn't quite sure why
he was interested in this because it
didn't fit in with anything on his
resume for hastings it was a new start
for six months he studied hard then went
to the state capitol to advocate for a
new kind of school
in california and he was able to
successfully create one of the first
laws in charter schools in the country
so
it allowed innovation and new operators
to come
in and was really an entirely new
concept for california
there was a new concept for hastings as
well
a familiar annoyance prompted reed
hastings to reinvent an industry
in 1997. he recalled getting a forty
dollar late fee for
a movie rental in this 2005 appearance
on charlie rose i remember i didn't want
to tell my wife about it
and i thought oh great now i'm kind of
compromising the integrity of my
marriage over this
late fee so of course i did tell her
about it but
it made me think i can't be the only one
who is struggling with this late fee
thing
and just started me thinking about the
internet and dvds
and how something could work without
late fees
the movie rental industry made around 8
billion
a year nearly all of it from the
dominant format of the day
vhs cassettes hastings saw the
opportunity in a new format
and a surprising new business dvds by
mail
but first he had to find out if the
disks could survive the us
mail so i stuffed a bunch of cds and
they couldn't buy dvds then put them
mailed them to myself
and then i had to wait for 24 hours to
see them come home
uh to see are they gonna be all
shattered in a bits along with the
my idea uh and then you know the next
day
three o'clock the postman arrives and i
rip open the envelopes and
the first one's in good shape the second
one's in good shape and the third one's
a good shape but i'm like
this sucker is going to work in 1998
hastings launched netflix as the first
online store to rent dvds
current redbox president mitch lowe was
a co-founder we started in an old bank
building
in fact our inventory was in the old
vault there was about seven or eight
people
everybody was dedicated to figuring out
how to do something uh disruptive in the
entertainment distribution business
they stocked up on dvds from retailers
like best buy
but there was a problem less than one in
a hundred households
owned a dvd player they cost nearly six
hundred dollars
and no one knew when they'd become more
affordable he committed everything to
dvds if dvds didn't happen he's got not
you know the company's nothing it's zero
[Music]
blockbuster and hollywood video
dominated the industry
with thousands of retail stores in
almost every neighborhood
if hastings wanted to compete he had to
build a better customer experience
so he innovated with an idea an easy to
use
subscription service for a monthly fee
members were allowed as many movies as
they could watch
with no late fees he realized having to
resell the customer every time is a bad
idea on a three dollar transaction
and he eventually got the company to go
to the subscription model and i think
that changed everything for him
that change was boosted by two popular
features
the queue a list of movies that the user
wanted
and computer generated recommendations
that were surprisingly accurate
michael pachter has followed netflix for
10 years as a research analyst with web
bush securities
the internet ordering mechanism and
interface was innovative the
recommendation engine was innovative
and the queue was innovative and i think
where netflix really thrived early
on was they were first to figure all
this stuff out
but for all their innovation netflix was
still barely on the radar
their revenues of 5 million at the start
of 2000
vanished next to blockbuster's 4.5
billion 900 times the size of netflix
in a bold and clever move hastings went
for help
to his biggest competitor everybody
loved blockbuster and blockbuster was
the golden child
and netflix was sort of this ugly step
child that was coming up and everybody
thought
well this thing's not going to last it's
not going to have legs it's going to die
we were having challenges as far as
acquiring customers
and we saw blockbuster as the greatest
single source for
rental customers so we actually reached
out to blockbuster
and invited them to become a strategic
partner
and and an investor blockbuster the
entertainment giant
founded entertaining john antiocho had
been blockbuster's ceo
for three years when netflix came
calling we thought well
if we're going to get in this business
we probably shouldn't give the
internet rights to another company for a
couple percentage points
and that's what caused us to keep
evaluating whether we wanted to enter
the business or not
i think that you know netflix was was
very lucky that blockbuster who was the
sleeping giant at the time
didn't do anything and they stayed
asleep because reed
is a gentleman i think if you had a
different ceo at
netflix who was a little bit cockier and
a little bit more brash
i think that blockbuster might have been
provoked into competing
there didn't seem much reason to compete
by the end of 2000
netflix was hemorrhaging money their
losses skyrocketed to 57 million dollars
it just sounded like another dot-com
idea
you know like e-toys and most investors
were just convinced netflix was you know
a niche little idea
people didn't want a subscription and it
would never take off
while netflix was struggling to become
profitable in 2000
reid hastings did the unexpected again
he took an additional job on
california's state board of education
any of you have tried to change large
organizations know that half the battle
is getting it on the right course
the second half of the battle is keeping
it on that course
he was appointed by then governor gray
davis you know if i was ever in a
foxhole i would like reid hastings with
me
because we would have discussions about
the next school board meeting
and we would argue over what that
decision would should be but once
you know we've kind of came to a
decision he went in there
and he held his ground and he got the
reforms established
netflix on the other hand was anything
but established
and heading into the dot-com dive how
the mighty have fallen
according to a recent study by morgan
stanley dean witter the average internet
stock is down
two-thirds from its 52-week high
having long planned to go public netflix
filed preliminary papers
as the market spiraled down we faced a
lot of obstacles in the first ipo
attempt the bubble had burst uh there
was the belief that
the business that internet businesses
had no substance behind them
uh there was the anthrax scare there was
9 11.
it was just like the perfect storm of
everything going in the wrong direction
hastings canceled the ipo in october
2001
netflix had to lay off a third of the
company netflix was on the brink of
disaster
i think that between 1999 and 2002
netflix could have gone under at any
time
had serious competition arisen
as the year was closing hastings got the
break he needed
the price of dvd players plunged
and hastings slipped a coupon for a free
trial of netflix in nearly every new box
business took off
[Music]
with the company back on track the much
delayed ipo
became a reality in 2002
netflix went public the stock rose 12
percent
the first day to 16.75
but it was a double-edged sword keith
terry tracks netflix as the managing
director of internet research at
canaccord genuity
going public got them a lot of attention
not just from
consumers but also come from competitors
and so they were going to start
seeing pretty significant competition
from companies like walmart and
entrenched players like blockbuster
walmart launched its competing service
in 2003.
a year later blockbuster also jumped in
we initially launched kind of the same
way netflix did which is free trial
membership
you know one of the most beautiful words
in the you know american language is
free
and that was getting us reasonable
growth
blockbuster's monthly fee was also two
dollars less than netflix
igniting a nasty price war netflix
slashed its price blockbuster countered
walmart edged under both so blockbuster
cut to rock bottom in a conference call
on the end of the year earnings
hastings declared blockbuster has thrown
everything but the kitchen sink at us
quite frankly myself and a couple of key
members of our management team were
sitting in my office listening to the
conference call
someone said well why don't we send him
a kitchen sink
i said good idea next day we shipped one
out
at that point the rivalry was definitely
established
the fierce competition on multiple
fronts took its toll
netflix stock plunged 75
analyst michael pachter commented that
netflix is a worthless piece of crap
with really nice people running i was
convinced that blockbuster would compete
effectively
and so it seemed to me that if
blockbuster
was determined to retain its customers
the netflix would disappear
hastings wasn't going down without a
fight he sacrificed profits to drive
back the competition
and maintain the company's growth it
became a war of attrition
the view that you had out there was that
netflix wasn't going to be able to
survive
uh this this level of competition from a
lot of people and that
blockbuster and then walmart were
ultimately just going to squeeze the
profits
out of netflix and i think what both
companies found in pretty short order
was this business was a lot harder than
they thought
while the battle with blockbuster and
walmart raged
reed hastings suffered a personal
setback for four years
hastings had championed public school
reform on california's state board of
education
but when he pushed for more english and
bilingual programs
he was pushed out by democratic
representatives it was a blow to him
and it was surprising and it was
i would think somewhat even humiliating
to be turned down by your own political
party
but he said if this is the issue that
you want to kick me off the state board
about then i go
proudly with my head held high hastings
focused his attention
on his company's battle for the dvd by
mail business
and in the middle of 2005 the tide began
to turn
walmart pulled out giving netflix their
rental customers
in exchange for promoting their sales
blockbuster was gaining subscribers but
losing
hundreds of millions of dollars now it
was hastings turn
to call someone nice we're not against
blockbuster they're all nice people
but our goal is to offer a better
service that consumers prefer us to them
and that eventually that does result in
them closing in 2007 at the sundance
film festival in utah
antiocho said he was called to a private
summit with hastings
to explore the possibility of a deal his
preference would have been
for netflix to buy blockbuster online
and what we proposed back was a merger
it never got beyond talks
because of concerns about antitrust
regulations
by 2008 antiocho was gone and
blockbuster backed away from its online
business they lost
hundreds of millions of dollars trying
to compete with netflix and they just
didn't have the cash to keep up
competing at the level and you knew at
some point
they were going to have to give up and
ultimately that's what happened
it was a triumph for netflix but no
sooner had hastings secured the movie by
mail business
then he launched a new service that
would mean the demise of the dvd
netflix delivered its billionth dvd in
2007.
hastings was about to reinvent his
company with a service that promised to
make dvd by mail
obsolete streaming video online
it was what he had foreseen from the
very beginning of netflix
it just took a decade to arrive if
there's anything you would want to bank
on
it's the technology will keep making
bandwidth
faster and cheaper bandwidth may have
been cheaper
but not the shows themselves unlike dvds
netflix needed a license for every movie
it streamed
and fees were astronomical andrew
wallenstein is an editor for the
hollywood news daily variety
i think the kind of titles netflix first
started out with streaming was probably
the bottom of the barrel it was kind of
the
the movies or tv programs that were long
forgotten
not the best stuff i remember making
you know a mocking comment and a
research note about how
no one wanted to see revenge of the
nerds 3 when it was a new movie back in
you know the early 90s
so they certainly didn't want to see it
in 2007
even if they did netflix could only
stream to one device
the personal computer we don't watch
movies on our pc
he's going to stream to the pc who cares
and we thought it was nuts we really
thought he was nuts
so hastings offered the new service to
subscribers for nothing
and when he then announced and we're
going to provide this for free
we were sure he was nuts
[Music]
he pursued even more content adding
eleven thousand titles in less than two
years
and finally he secured a breakthrough
deal for first run movies and shows
i think you'd have to go back a few
years to the deal that they struck with
stars
which enabled them to get some great
films out of the sony library the disney
library
and they only made that deal for
something like 20 million dollars which
in retrospect was
the steal of the decade deals followed
with many of the major studios
and it's my pleasure to introduce
netflix ceo reed hastings
more impressive was how rapidly netflix
expanded the world of streaming
to geek gadgets the ipad has been a
tremendous success for us and almost
every entertainment system
on the planet content and access drove
phenomenal growth
by 2011 subscribers hit 20 million
topping 2 billion dollars in revenue had
grabbed the attention of industry
goliaths
amazon apple google and facebook they're
all 800 pound gorillas and this is sort
of the danger point for netflix
if you're thinking of any time where
they may
have faced more pressure i can't think
of one surprisingly
the real pressure for netflix didn't
come from those other tech giants
but from a series of spectacular
self-inflicted wounds
in july 2011 netflix announced that it
was raising its monthly subscription fee
60 percent 800
000 subscribers defected two months
later
a contrite hastings apologized we're
making this video today to apologize in
person
he went on to announce that netflix
would split its dvd and streaming
businesses
the price increase remained but dvd by
mail would become
a new brand quickster the move
fell flat customers and shareholders
continued to flee
dumping subscriptions and stock netflix
now in a downward spiral was forced to
backtrack
netflix pushing the rewind button today
the company coming out with a big
flip-flop
saying that quickster is dead and that
the dvd and streaming services
are back under one umbrella now the
reason for the reversal is simple
customers just didn't like it hastings
delivered yet another apology
this time for moving too quickly
quickster became the symbol
of uh netflix not listening
and we quickly um change course on that
and we're going to stick with dvd as
part of the netflix brand
it was an epic collapse netflix lost
almost
two-thirds of its value in three months
including
a stunning 2.3 billion in one day
and if that wasn't enough bad news
netflix and stars
parted ways depriving netflix from newer
films from disney and sony
leaving the impression that netflix was
losing content
as it raised prices hastings moved
quickly
and announced new content deals with
dreamworks animation
relativity amc cw and others
despite the stumbles hastings says he
never considered stepping down
he said he wants to be measured by the
success of 12 years
rather than the mistakes of 12 weeks i
think reed has changed the way
we all think about consuming
entertainment he's expanded the options
and the way
you get movies i would not count out
reid hastings and netflix
i think again that they are a company
that
knows their challenges that they don't
hide from them
there's very few companies that have
done this many things
and succeeded and you know 12 years
later you know again
it's one of those companies where you
may not like the company but you can't
argue
about its successes